EMCEE: Next up we have Ibrahim.
He's come from a
world where he used
to program robots, humanoid
robots to play football,
and then doing
big data analysis.
And now he's going to
help you supercharge
your games with YouTube.
So please welcome Ibrahim.
IBRAHIM: I think everyone here
likes the free Google UAs,
right?
So I'm happy to, before
starting my presentation,
I'm up today here, to announce
that you get a YouTube.
You get a YouTube.
Everyone gets a YouTube
in this audience.
It's great, right?
So it's good today to see
that you are still like bright
and you are still
good in the afternoon.
I'm Ibrahim Ulukaya from
the New York City office,
from the YouTube API
developer relations team.
And today, we'll see like some
great videos from YouTube.
So let's talk about why
you should use YouTube.
And then we'll go
through the why
should you use YouTube APIs.
And in the third
phase, we'll talk
about the different
developer ecosystems.
We'll talk about all different
verticals with support.
And we'll see how actually
games or your apps
can play with YouTube, and what
are the actual opportunities
you can take from there.
And I'm sure we'll have some
time for Q&A. If not, I'll
be around and if
there's something
we want to dig deeper, we can
even meet at board meetings
tomorrow as well.
So YouTube, besides being
the most major video sharing
platform, did you also guys know
that it's the second biggest
search engine on the web?
One billion users, unique
users, visit YouTube each month.
And those users they see
six billion hours of video,
they watch six billion
hours of video each month.
I always blame the cat videos.
Can we?
What about the mobile?
Like right now we see
that 25% of the traffic
is coming from the mobile,
and it's growing like rapidly.
Can you still blame
the cat videos?
Or the cats?
They are getting clever, right?
[CAT MEOWING]
So why you should use YouTube,
if you don't have a channel
and you don't have
like a presence.
But you can actually make
videos with almost no budget.
And you don't even have to
make content to become popular.
You know, actually, our
players share the videos,
and you can share
those videos as well.
And what are your goals
should be on YouTube?
You can actually
raise awareness.
Raise awareness or make
your games go viral.
You can even raise
revenue from there.
You can research
and support users.
You can actually get
feedback from your users.
And this was actually
research done in 2011.
And I'm sure the numbers are
growing up higher from there
even.
And they select
the people who play
video games more than seven
hours a week, and from ages
from 13 to 35.
And they said-- 95% of them
said-- they are actually
watching the video game
videos on YouTube as well.
And what about the YouTube APIs?
So nowadays, the YouTube API
is almost equal to YouTube.
You can do almost
everything you do on YouTube
through the YouTube
APIs as well.
And when your app plays
with YouTube APIs,
it creates awesomeness.
It was like pretty
much a warm-up,
let's go on to the
developer ecosystem.
So we divided the developer
ecosystem into four,
and we'll talk about
each developer ecosystem
with its APIs.
And the examples
coming from there,
I like to see that what are
they related topics for the game
developers here.
The first vertical
is the creation.
The creation is the
creation of the content,
uploading a new content
on YouTube basically.
And the second one
is discovery, which
actually are finding new videos.
You are sharing those
videos with your gamers.
And the third one is analytics.
You are checking
out how your videos
are doing, how your
channels are, like
how much popular
they are on YouTube.
And you can even use promotions.
You can promote your apps.
You can promote your
channels through the YouTube.
And the fourth one is
the content management.
In this site you can actually
get revenue from that.
Let's start with the creation.
I'm sure most people
already familiar
with this game, the FIFA game.
And in the 2013 version, they
implemented a one click share
to YouTube.
So the user is like
playing the game,
he actually just wants to share
to YouTube from the replay.
They can just click one button
without leaving the game.
They can share those replay
to the YouTube right away.
So they can show it to their
friends how they play the game.
They can show it
to other people.
Other people can just
get a taste of it.
And your game gets more popular.
Lots of people like
to show these videos.
And we always like saw that
one of the really good ways
to get the games popular
is word of mouth.
So you are looking for
a new game to play,
or your friend just
comes to you and says
that, I found a really nice game
like you want to check it out?
And one really easy way
to check about the game
is just going to YouTube.
And see those footages
and see those replays
and see how the game is going.
Is it like something that
you're really interested in?
Or even those moments that
you're are like stuck in one
level.
You are playing
the "Angry Birds",
and you couldn't find like
how to pass that level
and you're looking
for like a solution.
Rather than giving up the game,
you can just go to YouTube
and find someone who
played the same level.
And your gamer
reaches his goals,
and maybe just finds
out and gets happy
and keeps playing
the game from that.
And for the APIs,
how they use this API
and how they implement this.
One of the major APIs
we have is the Data API.
Data API is where
you're actually
getting all the
content from YouTube
or putting like new
content over there.
You actually get
all the metadata.
You search new
content, new videos.
And don't think about code,
that's messy Java code here.
But, all I want to say
is in the last two lines,
I'm just creating a video insert
request and then executing it.
And this will
[? automatically ?]
insert a video on YouTube.
And you can do it through
like different libraries,
different languages as well.
And all the code
here actually will
be-- all the presentation--
will be shared,
so don't tackle on the
code or anything else.
And they're all available
in the developer website
as well as on
GitHub open source.
I actually want
to share something
quick on like a Data API.
So this is our
Google API Explorer.
I'm sure if you guys are
already using the APIs,
you've seen this one.
That you don't have to
actually implement everything,
you can actually just try the
APIs from this console easily.
Or even if you want to change
a parameter or something else,
you can just go here and
check out the parameter.
Let me try to get
like-- so here we
just want to get
like the metadata.
We just want 10 results.
All I want to do is actually
create a source link request,
just searching
videos on YouTube.
So I want to just like see
the videos on YouTube API
with the query.
And I want all the
videos in my result.
And I'm executing this
request, and all done.
We have like some videos
from the YouTube API overview
and anything about YouTube APIs
from Google Developers as well.
So let's get back
to the presentation.
And besides you
sharing those videos,
you actually want to
also like play back
those videos inside your games.
So you can actually use the
in-game video playbacks.
On Android we we have
the Android player API,
which is super easy to
just implement player view,
create a listener, just
implement this listener.
And you have the
video inside your app
without leaving your app.
And iOS and other platforms,
we support the iframe player.
You actually show the
video inside the iframe.
I will actually come to that
in the next presentation,
in the next slides.
And one of the examples
here was EveryPlay.
EveryPlay created a
platform that if people
don't want to go and have
the resources to implement
all the YouTube APIs and upload,
they create a middle layer
that, using their
platform or data API,
you can just easily share your
content on YouTube right away.
This was like one of
the games they played,
a shot from that, "Bad Piggies."
And I will show you guys
how they should do that.
So they're actually getting
all the media frames
from the game play, with Unity.
And they package them
with the webm encoder.
They are using the
VP8 for video encoding
and Vorbis for the
audio encoding.
And they are packaging
into like a video file.
And from that video file,
they are uploading it
with YouTube APIs to YouTube.
So if you don't have the
resources to implement
this framework, you can
actually use the API as well.
And one painful
thing that we always
hear from our developers'
authorization particles,
people-- like once they want to
upload some content-- they need
to go authorize and upload
to their own account.
And we made it like
really easy to authorize.
You have like two options going
either through the [INAUDIBLE]
OAuth2 or the Google+
sign in as well.
On Android, we support the
Google aacount credentials.
You just create a Google
account credential
and say that you
are using OAuth2
and it handles all the
authorization for you.
You don't have to save
any passwords or user
names as well.
NIS, we have the OAuth2
controller touch.
And just like having
this on the one line,
you've actually got
a way with OAuth2.
And how many people
here still remember
this photo or this video?
Wow, almost everyone.
So this was the Red
Bull sort of jump.
And this was actually sent
with the YouTube live platform.
And YouTube live is
getting like really popular
nowadays as we recently opened
up the YouTube live streaming
capability to almost everyone.
And it's getting really popular
between the game developers
because they want
to actually share,
they want to let their gamers to
share their content right away
as a live stream.
One of the early launch
partners from that was elgato.
They created like a box,
basically an HDMI capture box.
So they're just
getting an HDMI input
from any console,
any game platform,
even from like mobile devices.
And they are using
the YouTube APIs,
the YouTube live
streaming API basically.
And from there, they are sending
all the live streaming frames
to YouTube platform.
And people can just
watch from there.
Another example was like XSplit.
They created like a software
solution, rather than
the hardware solution.
And people can just
go from their computer
and just do the authorization,
and create like the settings
from there.
And once they create the
stream and start stream, voila,
and it goes to the
YouTube from there.
They start streaming
live to YouTube.
So how did they do that?
They used YouTube
live streaming API.
There are a few
terminologies here.
One is the broadcast, the event.
This is the event
address on YouTube.
And there is stream.
The stream is coming
from you, your device.
And once you bind it, you
are actually on stream.
Your devices, like
frames, show up
in the event on the
YouTube website.
And we made it
back this flexible,
that you can actually
change the-- use
a few different
streams into the event.
So without changing the event
address, or the YouTube watch
page, you can actually put
in like different streams.
And if you are a
content partner,
you can actually put cuepoints,
which are in-stream ads.
You can put advertisements
inside those live streams
as well.
And like the code is like
really similar if you
are using like the
[INAUDIBLE] output libraries.
You just set a title,
end time, start time,
putting in privacy
selections and just inserting
the live broadcast.
And one of the things I actually
want to talk to you about
was YouTube Direct Lite.
So that can be actually
really helpful.
You want to actually have your
gamers upload their content,
but you wanted to share
those content too.
So YouTube Direct Lite
makes it available to get
either feedback or get
shared content uploaded
into your playlist.
So they still technical
upload their own accounts.
But if you have like
a playlist idea,
all those videos come
to your playlist.
And from an easy
tool, you can actually
moderate all these videos
from that tool as well.
So it looks like--
well, on this one
I will show the mobile versions
as well, that people just
can upload their platforms.
If they have like some
videos they can submit--
and I wasn't authorized
so it will fail--
but then you moderate
those videos.
It comes to like an easy
moderation website for you.
And you can click which
videos you are interested in.
So you can accept or
reject those videos
and embed the whole playlist
into your own website
or into your app.
And all those
playlist they choose
starts playing inside your app
or wherever you embedded it.
There you go.
I have like some playlist.
I see like some pending
videos and I approve them.
If I approve them they
actually come here,
and they actually
come to my playlist.
Or I can just reject them.
So like if there is a video
that I'm not interested in,
I can easily get over it.
And I created like an Android
and iOS version for this one.
So actually you can
either use that.
They're all open source.
You can change it.
Also, they have like the best
practices for using the YouTube
APIs on the Android
and iOS platform.
It's like most of
the YouTube APIs
are uploading, showing new
content, playing new content.
So if you are like starting
to use YouTube APIs,
I encourage you to go there
and check out these examples
and use the code
you learn from that.
They're all on the open source
under our GitHub channel,
Github.com/YouTube.
So we talked about the
main creative side.
Let's talk about the
[INAUDIBLE] discovery part.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-Wouldn't it be amazing
if Google could understand
that the words that you use
when you're doing a search,
well, they aren't just words?
They refer to real
things in the world.
That a building is a
building, and an animal
is an animal, and
that they're not just
random strings of characters.
If we can understand that
those words are talking
about those real
world things, then we
can do a better
job of getting you
just the content that
you want off the web.
-The way Google is trying
to build information
about real world connections is
by building a knowledge graph.
A knowledge graph is about
collecting information
about objects in the real world.
The object could be a
person, could be a book,
could be a movie, and many
other types of things.
For example, for
a famous person we
collect relevant
data about them,
such as their date of
birth or how tall they are.
We can also connect that person
to closely related objects
in the knowledge graph.
-Let's say you're interested--
[VIDEO PLAYBACK ENDS]
IBRAHIM: Actually, we can cut
it short a little bit here.
And so Google they had the good
knowledge graph, so how can
we use it on YouTube?
Like when we are looking to find
like some videos related to us,
or we are just
trying to find videos
with our own game
or another topic?
So rather than just
giving a query,
we can actually use those
queries to go to Freebase API.
And get the most related
topics from those Freebase API,
from the knowledge graph.
And once we have the
ID, we can actually
put those ID into
our YouTube search.
Rather than putting
the query line
as I did before as
a YouTube API, now
I can just say YouTube
API find a related topic
and put the topic ID here.
And this way I will get the
videos that are really related
to that topic, not only
the queries I tell.
I'm actually kind of like
breaking the rules a little bit
here.
So I had a different
example before.
But we are doing like a
new YouTube dev channel,
and I had like some
examples for that.
They are actually still kind
of in the allotment phase,
but why not show them?
So this is one of
the places where
I was like playing with
the YouTube public API.
So let's say I was
like in test of FIFA.
So when I say FIFA, FIFA
could be like the-- I'm just
going to the YouTube topic API.
I see it is like m the
Football Federation or Football
Association, or is it the game?
Or is it that's the World Cup?
Like if I search on
YouTube, it could
be like cutting results
from each one of them.
But when I search
with the topic API,
then I have the videos that are
related to only for that event.
So I show this thing.
And I say maybe the
game series, then
I will have like the
videos that are related
to the game series-- for
the FIFA game series--
rather than the FIFA World Cup.
And I said you can actually
use the iframe player
for different things.
[GUITAR MUSIC PLAYING]
Like one of the developers
used the iframe player just
to create like a whole
instrument learning app.
But you can actually
create like a whole game,
just playing with
YouTube videos.
Or you can embed those
videos in different ways,
different like really
fancy ways to put
into like a gaming platform.
And it's really easy using
the iframe player API.
Iframe player API is just like
you put the JavaScript in.
You create it, and
then you just say
that you want to create
a YouTube player.
You put the parameters,
and then you
will have the player easily.
I will show you in
a live demo here.
So all I had was just like
creating the YouTube iframe
API.
And I set the player this
height, this width, and just
a video.
And once I created
it, [INAUDIBLE]
I have like the video player.
You can actually put it as
an iframe inside your app,
inside your game,
and everywhere else.
And we talked about creation
and discovery so far.
Let's talk about the analytics.
Analytics is the part
that actually when
you use the data API, you
get like the major statistics
like how many likes,
how many people see.
But if you want to go
into deep, deep analytics,
you want to go get
geographic data
or you want to get how
many users from which
ages are actually
seeing those videos,
then you can actually
use the analytics.
Or you want to promote your
app or your game from there.
That's not really actually
correlated with the game,
but it was like once
of the music industry.
They played like
with analytics API.
And The Next Big Sound
actually created a nice app.
It's almost like a game,
actually I want to tell.
That you actually want to
play with your analytics.
You just click if you are like
tracking with different music
artist, record labels,
you want to actually get
like how they are doing.
They want to predict how will
the next record, next song
will sell.
Or how much would it be popular.
So they track through like
different social media,
and one of them is YouTube.
And they see like the video
views, the people's interaction
through that, how the
channel is popular,
and their comments and
everything from that.
And then there was like audience
analytics, tubular display.
They are actually getting
all that analytics data
from four different
channels they are managing.
And they made like it really
easy [INAUDIBLE] platform.
And they use analytics API.
Basically in analytics API
there are different dimensions
you can actually get data from.
The metrics that you
want to get the data,
from different metrics.
You have filters.
You can filter data and you
will get a report from there.
And actually, I
will want to show
one easy demo I created from
that, using that analytics API.
Like you can actually just--
you don't need to create a demo.
You can actually get
all the data easily.
So I was getting
like [INAUDIBLE]
at Google I/O. I was
getting all the what
are the most popular
videos for each continent
and like the total views
from each continent
for those videos.
I was getting for
like different days.
Like as they go change for
different days as well.
And we talked about a
bit on the analytics.
Let's finish up with enterprise,
or the content management side.
Now you have like
videos, rather than just
making your games popular.
Since you had like
the game on there,
you had like some content from
there, you have some rights.
And you can actually
even raise revenue out
of those, all those uploads.
And you can actually,
on that side,
you can use the
content ID platform.
Rather then tracking it
with like one by one,
you can use an API to
track everything from that.
Zefr was one of the
apps, that they're
using the content ID platform.
They created an app like
this that you can actually
just easily see
all the things that
are relevant to your
content, and you
can monetize all this
content from here.
And for that they use
the content ID API.
With the content ID API, you
manage the content owners.
If you are the content owner
of that channel, or all
the product, you can
actually upload videos
on behalf of that channel.
You can claim content and
manage advertising and revenue
generating option from there.
Here was an easy example then.
Before I was uploading just
a video to like my channel.
Now I'm uploading a video on
behalf of some content owner
to another channel
that I already manage.
And that was like the
four different verticals
we saw today.
The creation side was
uploading or seeing
other videos from there.
It was actually a
value on upload videos.
And on the discovery side,
we talked a little bit
about how you can find
the related videos
or show in-game
videos to your gamers.
On the analytics side, we talked
about how you can actually
get more deep analytics, or
you can promote your own data
or content.
And in the content
management and last vertical,
we talked about how you
can actually create revenue
in a programmatic way, rather
than doing it like one by one.
And here are a few links
that I want to share.
Our web site will
be hopefully will
be like a total [? relief ?]
in a week or two.
That will be like
a great website.
I've already showed like
some preview for you guys.
[INAUDIBLE] on YouTube.com/dev.
And we have an API blog.
We share like the things
that coming or changing
on the APIblog.youtube.com.
We have the Google+ and
Twitter accounts as well.
And you can also get more
detailed documentation from
the developers at
google.com/YouTube.